we're here at the nailed it holiday
event in Hollywood with Nicole and
Jacques themselves tell me a little bit
about what's going on here today there
is a lot there's an ice skating rink
there's a little Instagram booth there's
giant macaroons big old candy canes
there's a lot there's a super special
moment happening with the Boys and Girls
Club of America right like a little
holiday treat
and then Jacques and I will taste and
judge it and then they'll have their own
nail that moment a team from a lot of
different states meeting here and this
is the final yes the Olympics have
nailed it for these Turin's this is the
show for you nailed it
what are three foolproof ways or tips to
winning nailed it I think parchment
paper yeah nobody ever uses parchment
paper and that helps your cakes come out
of your pans faster that I didn't know
smart too when you bake bake very fast
and save time for decoration they all do
the opposite they spent so much time at
the beginning no time for decoration and
decoration is actually working the show
very important important
[Music]
because I already started the clock get
to bacon go the third one is you bring
me a nice gift if you find me a husband
I will let you win anything you want are
we helping us on that way also yes I
will vote for you too you know I would
say okay you caught one that's when fan
favorite Wes crashed the interview this
is the show that I think we didn't even
know we needed why do you think it is
that it resonates so much I think it
because you kind of see yourself in it
and then also you watch and you're like
I can do better than that even if you
actually can yes she nailed it yeah I
think that people we say I can do better
we're all we're laughing with them not
at them and it's just it's good-natured
and just makes you feel good and if that
weren't sweet enough
Jacques broke down his tips for making
the perfect cup of hot chocolate it's
only one way of making hot chocolate so
good hot chocolates it's using real
chocolates not cacao powder we use real
chocolates and good milk that's pretty
much it I think it's fantastic
what's bad milk is a good milk what's
bad America will put milk with a lot of
fat full fat milk I will not use that
stuff with zero not for the hot
chocolate is the diet is not diet for
the hot chocolate the real thing we
bring you to a boil and then you're
going to add a little bit of whipped
cream and it's a bit of marshmallow
little bit of chocolate pieces you can
add a little bit of vodka in it can't
forget the podcast
[Laughter]
[Music]